موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم وصل منتخب
الارجنتين الفائز بكاس العالم قطر 2022
الى العاصمه الارجنتينيه يونس ايرس وكاله
بانتظار الفقاء ميسي الاف المشجعين الذين
قضوا ليلتهم انتظار فريقهم الوطني وكان
منتخب الارجنتين قد فاز في نهائي بطوله
العالم على المنتخب الفرنسي لركلات
الترجيح باربعه اهداف لهدفين بعد انتهى
الوقت الاصلي والاضافي للمباراه بالتعادل
بثلاثه اهداف لكل فريق وهذه صور مباشره
للوصول الفريق الارجنتيني يا مطارس
اتفق وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيون على تحديد
سقف لسعر الغاز وعلى اليه التنفيذ وقال
نائب رئيس الوزراء تشيكين الاتفاق سيفعل
بشكل الين اذا استمر سعر الغاز لمده ثلاثه
ايام في تجاوز حاجز 180 يورو لكل ميغاوات
في الساعه واضاف ان تسعيره سيكون مارينا
لان الهدف وضمان الامدادات واستقرار
الاسواق الماليه في المقابل رفض الكرمل
القرار وقال انه هجوم على اليه تحديد
السوق السعر وقال انه سيتخذ الرد المناسب
بشانه
سبايك وشؤون الاسرى والمحررين الفلسطينيين
استشهاد الاسير ناصر ابو حميد في مستشفى
اساف هارون الاسرائيلي نتيجه تدهور حالته
الصحيه للراعي اصابته بسرطان الرئه منذ
اكثر من عام وحملت الهيئه حكومه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه الكامله عن وفاته بسبب ما وصفته
بالسياسه القتل الطبي المتعمد التي تتبعها
اداره سجون الاحتلال بحق الاسرى
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
للترايس ان الاقبال الضعيفه على صناديق
الافتراعي في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
التونسيه يعكس حاجه الحكومه الى الانخراط
في عمليه اكثر شمولا لتوسيع نطاق المشاركه
السياسيه واضاف ان بلاده ستواصل دعم تطل
على شعب تونسي في حكومه ديمقراطيه خاضعه
للمسائله
في دوري قال مركز كارتر الدولي لمراقبه
الانتخابات ان نسبه الاقبال الضعيفه على
التصويت في الانتخابات التشريعيه التونسيه
تشير الى ان خريطه الطريق التي نفذها
الرئيس قيس سعيد لم تنجح في توحيد البلاد
واضاف ان الانتخابات التونسيه تفتقر الى
الشرعيه
وكان رئيس الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في تونس قد قال ان نسبه
الاقبال في الانتخابات التشريعيه بلغت
11.22 في المئه واكد ان الهيئه رصدت نحو
1800 مخالفه
واعلنت حركه النهضه ايداع نائب رئيس
الحركه ورئيس الحكومه الاسبق علي العريض
السجن فيما تعرف بقضيه التسفير الى بؤر
التوتر وقالت الحركه ان القراره محاوله
يائسه ومفضوحه بمن وصفتها بسلطه الانقلاب
ورئيسها قيس سعيد للتغطيه على الفشل الذري
للانتخابات التشريعيه
صوتت لجنه التحقيق اقتحام الكونغرس
الامريكي لصالح رفع توصيات الى وزاره
العدل لاجراء تحقيق جنائي مع الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وتتمثل التهم بعرقله
عمل الكونجرس والتامر بهدف الاحتلال على
الحكومه والتامر لتقديم تصريحات كاذبه
والدعوه للتمرد ومن المقرر ان ينشر
التقرير النهائي يوم غد الاربعاء بعدما
اللجنه تحقيقها الموسع الذي امتد لنحو
عامل
[موسيقى]